Tom's approach towards Russia has been
one of the most controversial parts of
his short time in office so far.
It seems that the US president wants to
develop a new friendship with this old
rival.
The thing is that this isn't breathing
so easy and that's because Beijing is
standing between them,
Russia who's in Moscow without any
doubt.
One of the most controversial issues is
the fascination trump seems to have with
Russia and its charismatic leader,
Vladimir Putin,
insinuations messages of support and the
election of senior officials who were
close to the Kremlin years met with
Russian President Vladimir Putin and the
Kremlin gave him the order of friendship
and $2,000.
13,
the new administration to where it is
just being shaped right now.
It is absolutely a gift for him.
He couldn't have dreamed about anything
like that just a few months ago.
The question really is,
is trump trying to seduce the Russian
leadership or as some are saying,
is there something suspicious about this
developing relationship?
It would be fair to say that trump's
approach to Russia could have an
explanation according to some analysts,
advisors in the White House may have
told trump to try to be remembered and
make history by being the leader who has
the same success with Russia as Nixon
and Kissinger had with Chinese
Nixon's had used his mouth China on the
20th,
first of February,
1972.
One of the most important events in
decades took place that day.
Richard Nixon arrived in Beijing.
It was the first ever visits you've
communist China by a US
president
for Nixon on unknowns there for
maintain.
The entire trip was broadcast around the
world and it was major,
major news.
Millions of people held their breaths as
they saw Nixon descending the stairs of
Air Force One and setting force in the
Chinese capital city
generations in the years ahead.
We'll look back and thank for this
meeting that we have in this past week.
We continue.
Let's actually go back at this and see
what this visit really met.
What were the goals of this visits and
what made it possible.
So we're going to travel back in time,
but so you October the first 19,
49,
this was the date that China was
declared,
I think People's Republic of China,
the Communists led by now had one the
Chinese civil war,
and they took power of this new country.
This new regime was completely hostile
to Washington DC.
In fact,
only a year later trips of the Chinese
army,
you participated in the Korean War to
support Pyongyang's regime,
therefore confronting the US faced as a
result of this better runs,
violent fight,
and did thousands of casualties on each
side.
There were no intentions of establishing
any diplomatic relations.
It would be fair to say that from that
time on China in the US were enemies.
You have to move in this neighborhood.
In the meantime though,
relations between Beijing and Moscow
with very,
very different.
It is true that Mao had never goes on
with the Soviet leaders who had,
by the way,
you supported other people to be the
leader of the Chinese Communist Party.
However,
despite all of these differences,
a Russian Chinese alliance was almost
inevitable.
On the one hand,
the Soviet Union needed to control or at
least influence the other grades,
communist power.
On the other hand,
Mao's China desperately needed the USSR
for economic,
technological as well as military
support.
The support was so generous in fact that
between the in 1954 in 1959,
the Ussr spent seven percent of the
government's resources assisting China.
It's even say that this was the largest
technological transfer in fight.
All of this differences started to
emerge in almost every part of their
relationship and the alliance got weaker
and weaker until well that completely
broke apart relations.
We're getting very census.
There was the assault of the US embassy
in Beijing in 1967,
and then the first armed encounter took
place in 1970 disease.
When numerous during this fight,
a few days later,
the Soviet bombarded Chinese troops
deployed in the area.
The conflict didn't go any further,
but for days there was a feeling in the
air that this could be the start of a
significant war.
Moscow even considered sending troops
from the Warsaw Pact countries which
remain your objective
two,
so you said that's in order to prevent a
potential nuclear attack by Russia.
Nixon contacted Moscow to make it
perfectly clear that the US would never
accept something like that happening
under any circumstances in the
interrelations between these two.
Communist nations broke down completely
at the time that both Nixon and his
famous national security advisor,
Henry Kissinger,
just only need to take a famous saying
and make it their own one over my enemy
is my friend,
and once that said that they started to
put it into action and two years later
Nixon was in Beijing relations between
the USA and China and moved on slowly.
In fact,
it wasn't until 1979 with Jimmy Carter
in office that full relations with the
nation were established,
but the truth is that Nixon's trip to
China made room for a period of
successful relationships between the two
nations.
In 1972 bilateral trade between the two
nations didn't even reach a billion
dollars.
Today the number is close to 600.
Really
things have been relatively friendly and
the US also made a solid ally against
the Soviet Union during the Cold War.
According to some analysts.
That's what trump is trying to achieve
with Russia.
The reenactment,
Nixon and strategy for Beijing,
Moscow.
This would explain the pro Russian
attitude of the current president's
things are very much different now than
they were in 1969
enrollments between China,
Russia,
relations between China and Russia have
started to improve since the end of the
19 eighties with some treaties and
agreements being signed here and that,
but it all changed when Xi Jinping came
to power in 2012.
Since then,
relations have advanced quickly consider
what was said in 2016 by one of the
major players in the Chinese
government's the profundity ends.
The level of coordination between both
countries has reached a level we have
never seen before and it's.
Beijing seems to be certain about one
thing and alliance between China and
Russia would be very powerful from any
perspective today.
Both countries are cooperating like
they've never cooperated.
Thousand and 16.
Russia became the first Chinese oil
supplier with oil that arrives by lands.
This is something incredibly important
for China because in the case of the
conflict and the US would be unable to
block the island writing something it
could do if that's all it is,
arriving by sea.
Both countries have started to conduct a
joint military exercises.
They've also created economic and
technological bonds end up agreeing to
carry out projects to build
infrastructure which will connect both
countries.
So how about some examples of this?
Well,
let's have a look at the military
exercises.
Yes.
Russia and China.
Have you gone eight days of naval drills
in the South China Sea
seconds,
those economic
bombs
infrastructure for this one,
what better example than this?
After 20 years of talks,
construction has finally started on a
bridge between China and
Russia
is more.
These two countries have signed
important military agreements,
kind of has committed to spending
billions of dollars to buy it.
Some of the most modern equipment that
the Russian army has,
such as the s 400 surface to air missile
ends,
the most impressive weapon in the
rationale.
The sequoia at 35 fighter aircraft,
just to have a look at this incredible
today.
There are also many economic political
men's monetary agreements.
All of this has led to quite a lot of
concern in the United States.
Tiny Russian author just
sit there for just a second before you
start to get scared because everything
isn't quite as ideal as it sounds.
Both powers may have come together,
but there are still many elements that
separate them.
More mites potentially weaken this
unity.
For One,
China wants to be important and
influential in international politics
and that's employees becoming the leader
of Central Asia.
This is something that Russia certainly
doesn't want.
In their view,
the ex Soviet states in the region have
to remain under the influence of Moscow.
Further,
there are issues concerning their
economic relations.
The trade is unbalanced in favor of
Russia.
Russia has become a supplier of natural
resources to train.
For the last few years,
China has been supplying Russia with
Chinese manufactured goods,
which are more valuable.
You see China's position towards
international trade is very pragmatic.
Chinese people want to make money so
they know it's good for them to open
their markets to the world.
This is simply an idea that Russia
doesn't,
and then there was the issue with some
of Russia's partners like India.
Russia is the largest weapons supplier
in India and and obviously Beijing
doesn't like that at all,
so even though these two countries are
trying to get closer and all supporting
each other against the US,
we shouldn't expect a very solid
relationship between them after world.
China is eventually going to make a play
to become the leader in this
relationship and to Russia isn't just
going to lie down and accept that one.
So you'd be honest.
It doesn't seem very likely that
reenacting Nixon's strategy is possible.
This is largely because China is going
to strongly oppose this relationship,
but despite this,
if trump wants to earn the trust of
Moscow,
he will have to make some concessions
which would be difficult to accept in
Washington.
Okay.
Elimination of sanctions given you an on
the Ukraine and Syria,
the end of the anti missile shield among
others.
Susan is very demanding and even if a
good relationship is established between
Russia and the United States,
it is not clear whether this alliance
would be very effective as actually
stopping China.
This is one reason why Obama prefer to
strategy of surrounding China by
reaching agreements with the countries,
neighbors,
India,
Vietnam,
Malaysia,
and in this strategy,
the TPP was key.
It was of course because it was one of
the first things that trump flocks when
he arrived in the White House or any
time is going to be able to tell where
the trump strategy is going to work out,
but right now it's not looking very
promising.
So that's our opinion here.
Visual politic,
and we would love to know what you
think.
Do you think a Chinese Russian alliance,
there's going to be consolidated against
the USA.
What do you think trump will succeed in
a nixon like relationship with Moscow?
Let us know in the comments below and if
you did like this video,
please do give it a like.
It really helps us out and decent scribe
for brand new videos just like this
every week,
and that's on Mondays and on Thursdays,
so hit that subscribe button below and
thank you for watching.